there was some trevor lawrence news
yesterday coincidentally or not
his wedding is this weekend so he won't
be going to indianapolis to get his
surgically repaired non-throwing
shoulder examined
reportedly coming from his agent
undoubtedly everything is going well so
we can believe that completely and
entirely because agents
along with coaches and gm's never tell
anything other than the absolute
unvarnished truth they may as well walk
around attached to a polygraph machine
everything you say can be taken to the
bank
uh or or not um look i'm not concerned
about trevor lawrence's
left shoulder peter i i he'll be fine
he'll be good to go the jaguars are
gonna take him
um but you know the question of his
rookie season and how effective
he will be there is a connection there
to whether he's ready to go right out of
the gates when they open training camp
and and i remember when the timeline was
first announced after
the the procedure it was a little fuzzy
as to whether or not he's going to be
100 when it's time to to start
practicing but that's not going to
dissuade the jaguars for as much of an
upset as it would be for
the jets to not take zach wilson
multiply that by a thousand that's the
upset it would be for the jaguars to not
take trevor lawrence at this point
no they're taking trevor lawrence and uh
look i
i've already got the invitation from
urban meyer to come and listen to
at training camp to come and listen to
the ball coming out of trevor lawrence's
hand
because i said to him does that really
matter can you really hear something he
says yeah yeah
he said we you you come down here and
you can hear it too
so i'm gonna i'm gonna hold him to that
you can bet my little dispatch
out of jacksonville training camp is
okay
now i'm gonna tell you what this really
sounds like and maybe
nbc will give me a great microphone or
recording device
and i'll just hold it up like that to
see if we can actually hear
anything with the ball coming out of his
hand but
look i think mike i
i question right now deep down you know
obviously urban meyer told me that he'd
been thinking about this
for a year he'd been thinking about
doing this going back to last january
and he wasn't specific about which team
but
everybody knows that he and shot khan
have had a friendship slash
cordial relationship so i am sure
that urban meyer is watching the
jacksonville jaguars
tumble down and down and down and
after he understands what's going to
happen with them having the first pick
in the draft
i mean you know would he have really
gone to jacksonville
if you know if if they were going to
have like
the eighth pick in the draft this year
uh
they weren't gonna be able to get a
quarterback they were gonna have to
think about
you know scotch taping the quarterback
position together
and all that i mean it's pretty
convenient for him that he's able to
walk into a situation
with a perhaps a generational
quarterback
the most capped money of anybody and an
incredibly good draft situation
in his first year so i i i think
there's a pretty good reason why he took
this job
pete demolitis who is not producing the
show today but nevertheless is
subjecting himself to it has texted
that the current odds for trevor
lawrence as the number one pick in the
draft
are minus 10 000. that means peter
you'd have to wager 10 000 of your
hard-earned after-tax money
to win a mere 100 bucks on trevor
lawrence and it's probably a safe bet at
that if you want to make 100 bucks
just crack out 10 000 and put it on the
jaguars
taking trevor lawrence and for zach
wilson at number two it's minus 2
000. so again not as firm as as lawrence
but those are the first two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports